I want to talk briefly a story that a
number of viewers said David you should
really talk about this and this relates
to a requested recount in Florida in the
presidential election results over a
lawsuit now I'm going to discuss it not
because I believe that there is really
great news from Florida but because
enough people in our audience have asked
about it and if a dozen people have
emailed me about this there are probably
many many more who also are curious
about this there are some I would call
them more partial websites talking about
a lawsuit in Florida as a major
development that alleged voter flawed in
for Florida is triggering a recount
which might flip the results from Trump
to Clinton that is quite an exaggeration
what is happening is that three Florida
voters have filed a lawsuit they say
that Donald Trump didn't really win the
Florida presidential election why well
they say that it's because of hacking
malfunctioning voting machines and other
problems their demand is for a hand
recount of every paper ballot in florida
they may actually run out of time before
this even gets going an Orlando attorney
who's representing these three
plaintiffs his name is Clint Curtis said
that the defendants may not even respond
by the time that the Electoral College
meets on December nineteenth and he said
that he has received a deluge of reports
from voters across the state of problems
on Election Day people being turned away
at the polls people being told you've
already voted even though they believe
that they haven't and more of what the
Florida Division of Elections calls
minor issues I think that it is a really
important pack for progressives not to
pay too much attention to this the
margin in Florida the large margin of
victory for Trump was a hundred and
twelve thousand votes it is very
unlikely that this recount is even going
to get going even if a recount got going
if you really believe that there was
hacking you actually need an audit to
uncover that and a recount even if it
happens which it probably won't is
insanely unlikely to change a hundred
and twelve thousand vote margin of
victory and even if it did Florida only
has 29 electoral votes which is far
short of the 37 you need to block Trump
from getting the presidency another you
would also have to pick up Pennsylvania
or
Wisconsin it's a long shot but I think
it really just goes the idea that
Florida has to get it together we've
we've gone through these national there
yeah with that state before and when you
look specifically at some of the
counties in Florida I know this is like
a broken record but the machines they
use are the same machines that are used
in some of the not contested officially
but reportedly sketchy counties in other
important states like Michigan Wisconsin
in Pennsylvania so that voting machine
thing continues to be in the background
my advice to progresses don't hold your
breath because this is so unlikely to
happen and even if it does I talk to you
about the difference between a recount
and an audit and this was why when the
entire Jill Stein recount recount thing
got going I didn't really have high
hopes for it because even if I believed
that there had been something shady in
those states and the exit poll data
versus the reported poor voting data is
that minimum of raising some pretty fair
questions when you look at a recount
you're not actually following the path
from the intention of a voter to cast a
vote for candidate a all the way through
the handling of the ballot to whether
that person's intention was actually
reflected in how the vote was counted
that is what an audit is and that's not
even what was being discussed Pat and I
I've been making this point like a
broken record and I think some people
get it and some still don't I really
wonder what the odds makers have for
stopping Donald Trump what method is
more likely an electoral revolt or the
recounts going the opposite way I i
think the electoral revote as unlikely
as it is is the the most likely path to
stopping Trump I don't think recounts
and and this type of lawsuit is actually
going to make a difference